[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen ihnen allen
an meiner seite ist für den sport rudi
cerne hallo schön gute nacht und da sind
unsere themen von heute
langfristige entlastungen im
sommerinterview bezweifelt spd-chefin
esken dass die schuldenbremse 2023
eingehalten werden kann
hinter der front ein zdf team hat
erstmals die russische armee im
besetzten donbass begleitet
und ohne gegentor geht's weiter die
deutschen fußballerinnen treffen im em
viertelfinale auf österreich nach einer
perfekten gruppenphase
die preise für energie und lebensmittel
sind hoch und könnten weiter steigen und
die bundesregierung muss sehen ob und
wie sie die bürger unterstützt
spd-chefin esken sagte im
zdf-sommerinterview es brauche
langfristige entlastungen sie geht davon
aus dass die schuldenbremse erneut
ausgesetzt werden muss was
koalitionspartner fdp aber rigoros
ablehnt bernd benthin hat mehr
sommerinterview in historischen
klostermauern und mitten im krisen
sommer die spd parteivorsitzende in
ihrem wahlkreis im nordschwarzwald krieg
inflation drohne gasknappheit laut esken
ein nie dagewesener dauerdruck keine
regierung seit 1949 hatte so einen
schweren start und das ist nicht ganz
von der hand zu weisen dass sind sondern
schon sehr sehr schwer wiegende krisen
mit denen wir es zu tun haben es gehen
will weitere entlastungen vor allem für
menschen mit geringem einkommen
finanziert werden könnte das mit neuen
schulden die schuldenbremse dürfe es
deshalb auch 2023 nicht geben
ich glaube dass wir die schuldenbremse
erneut aussetzen müssen und dazu kommt
natürlich dass wir jetzt langfristig
auch entlastungen ermöglichen müssen und
dazu ist sicher auch ein starker beitrag
der hohen sehr sehr hohen einkommen der
so sehr hohem vermögen notwendig
aussetzen der schuldenbremse und
steuererhöhungen beides schließt der
ampel partner fdp kategorisch aus daran
wird die forderungen dann auch scheitern
glaubt die opposition werden sagt
kersten das heute fordert ist das gut
aber es reicht sich jetzt zu fordern
dann muss man es eben auch durchsetzen
und daran müssen sich dann messen lassen
die sozialdemokraten auch csu-chef söder
liefert heute einen eigenen entlastungs
vorschlag er will den tank rabatt
verlängern über den ganzen winter essen
hält das für falsch
tank rabatt auch da fordert der
bayerische ministerpräsident heute
verlängerung über den winter sehr
wichtig wäre ja dass der tank rabatt
auch tatsächlich an verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher weitergegeben wird das hat
hier nicht so geklappt es fehlt uns
nicht am geld das hat er es denn vor
kurzem auch gesagt es klingt nach
konfliktstoff für die ampel
in der ukraine gehen die angriffe im
donbass und dem süden des landes weiter
in der hafenstadt odessa soll nach
russischen angaben ein depot mit
westlichen waffen zerstört worden seien
raketenangriffe haben zudem ein
wohngebiet in progress kinder region
bonn jetzt getroffen laut behörden hat
es dabei tote und verletzte gegeben
nur selten haben wir die chance von der
anderen seite der front zu berichten aus
den besetzten gebieten
jetzt war unser reporter wienand
wernicke dort unterwegs mit der
russischen armee und entsprechend streng
kontrolliert in seiner berichterstattung
vier tage lang hatte die soldaten im don
was begleitet und in mehreren städten
versucht zu erfahren wie es den menschen
dort geht
kaputte straßen zerstörte brücken
unbewohnbare orte es ist eine reise in
ein gebiet das wochenlang heftig
umkämpft war organisiert und überwacht
wird die fahrt vom russischen militär
dass teile des ostens und des südens der
ukraine mittlerweile kontrolliert
lässig eine ruinenstadt wer überlebte
und geblieben ist hat nun kein wasser
keinen strom und nichts zu essen
russische behörden organisieren
humanitäre hilfe wir sind zusammen steht
auf den paketen die botschaft die
zukunft des dollars ist russland
ob sie lenski hier das sagen hat oder
putin ist mir völlig egal es darf nur
nicht weiter diese schreckliche
situation geben es soll jetzt nur ruhig
bleiben
doch daran glauben hier viele nicht es
herrscht angst vor der zukunft
ich fürchte dass der krieg zurückkommen
das wichtigste ist aber dass frieden
herrscht und dass es endlich ruhig ist
es
werden waffen präsentiert mit denen die
ukrainische armee gekämpft hatte
darunter systeme geliefert vom westen
eine art siegestrophäe und
psychologische botschaft an die nato
dass auch diese unterstützung der
ukraine nicht helfen würde
mario pohl im süden erlangte traurige
berühmtheit durch schwere bombardements
hier lässt nun russland bauen ein
krankenhaus und eine wohnanlage für 2500
menschen
die wohnung lässt das russische
verteidigungsministerium bauen danach
werden sie an die behörden der
volksrepublik dorn jetzt übergeben ein
wiederaufbau des donners würde
jahrzehnte dauern doch noch ist nicht
einmal ein ende der kämpfe in sicht für
die menschen bleiben es gefährliche
zeiten
im nordosten griechenlands ist ein
frachtflugzeug mit rüstungsgütern
abgestürzt alle acht insassen kamen ums
leben die antonow einer ukrainischen
fluggesellschaft war von serbien auf dem
weg nach bangladesch und hatte schon in
der luft feuer gefangen mehrere
explosionen behinderten die bergung an
bord befanden sich 11,5 tonnen munition
die unglücksstelle wurde weiträumig
abgesperrt
die hitzewelle kommt ab morgen zu uns
südeuropa leidet bereits seit tagen
unter extremen temperaturen und
waldbränden in portugal und griechenland
sind die feuer inzwischen weitgehend
unter kontrolle
spanien kämpft noch immer mit rund 20
bränden und in frankreich haben die
flammen allein in der region bordeaux
mehr als 10.000 hektar wald vernichtet
christoph testival
wasser ich brauche was hast du schon
dreh auf
mehr wasserdruck
die ganze nacht tobt der kampf
feuerwehrleute gegen feuer im wald
südlich von bordeaux kaum ist ein
brandherd eingedämmt jagen die männer
zunächst irgendwie klappt
das feuer dürfte nicht über die straße
springen also war unser einsatz ein
erfolg
trotzdem 14.000 menschen evakuiert über
10.000 hektar verbrannt der südwesten
frankreichs leidet und das ab heute bei
höchster hitzewarnstufe
derweil hat die spanische region
extremadura nahe portugal vielleicht das
schlimmste schon hinter sich doch noch
immer holen hubschrauber ihr wasser
minuten takt um es über den vorerst
letzten brandnester abzuwerfen die
anwohner bleiben fassungslos
die gegend hier ist eigentlich grün und
kühl im sommer jetzt aber brütend heiß
wie ganz im süden in cordoba oder
sevilla
und gerade schwappt die extreme hitze
bis rauf nach england ist in den
nachrichten dort thema nummer eins fast
alles rot auf der wetterkarte und 40
grad befürchtet es wäre ein neuer rekord
verantwortliche waren vorsichtig sein
und später an die anderen denken
vielleicht klopfen sie mal bei den
nachbarn fragen nach ob alle genug
wasser haben vor allem die ganz alten
und ganz klein
alle krankenhäuser sind in
alarmbereitschaft ein land wappnet sich
vor einer hier neuen gefahr mit allen
möglichen maßnahmen auch dieser arbeiter
streichen die gleise weiß weniger hitze
metall dann verbiegt vielleicht nichts
so die hoffnung in
deutschland müssen fast vier millionen
corona impfdosen von moderner vernichtet
werden weil das haltbarkeitsdatum
überschritten ist laut
gesundheitsministerium konnten sie nicht
gespendet werden die internationale
impfstoff allianz habe erklärt es gebe
keinen bedarf
insgesamt hatte das ministerium in den
vergangenen sieben monaten rund 134
millionen impfdosen verschiedener
hersteller eingekauft und jetzt kommen
wir zu den schnellsten männern der welt
und ich bin jeder schnellste aber okay
die top sprinter aus den usa gewinnen
gold silber und bronze über 100 meter
bei der leichtathletik-wm in den usa
fred curly rast in 98
sechs sekunden zum ersehnten gold
typisch usa erst stärker am himmel und
dann stärke über 100 meter 4 us sprinter
im finale und olympia-zweite fed curly
auf bahn vier im vorlauf schon 9,79
olympiasieger jacob's aus italien
verzichtete wegen einer verletzung
curlis krönung gold in 9,86 sekunden für
2 und 3 auch an die usa
weitsprung im sechsten versuch von fünf
auf eins der chinese wang acht meter und
36 der erste asiate platz eins marathon
wm rekord der äthiopier tola nach zwei
stunden und fünf minuten 36 und nach
11,9 sekunden steht die 100 meter
sprinterin gina lückenkemper im
halbfinale der wm als einzige deutsche
mit optimaler punktausbeute beendeten
deutschlands fußball-frauen dank eines
13 0 sieges gegen finnland die em
gruppenphase heute gab es dafür
unverhoffte abkühlung bei hohen
temperaturen heute erlebte die
bundestrainerin eine überraschung ganz
im gegensatz zum vorabend als alles
glatt lief gegen finnland nicht ganz so
berauschend wie die siege zuvor aber mit
echten highlight mit dem schönen treffer
der erstmals eingewechselten
frankfurterinnen nicole an juni zum 13 0
in bester feierlaune präsentiert sich
aber auch österreich nach einzug ins
viertelfinale gegen deutschland man
kennt sich aus der bundesliga wir wissen
dass dann eingespielt das erfahrenes
team kommt aber wir wissen auch wie man
die verteidigt aus der bundesliga
deshalb freue ich mich auf das tor ging
ist er recht an dass sie während der
heutigen wasserspiele aber sicher noch
nicht gedacht haben
und der belgier jasper philippsen
gewinnt die fünfzehnte etappe der tour
de france er setzt sich im massensprint
gegen landsmann baut von art durch das
gelbe trikot behältst jonas winkler aus
dänemark weiter im bergtrikot simon
herstellt
das war eine kurze sportlern am sonntag
und wir haben auch eine ganz schöne
hitze bei der tour de france die
schützen und das brot auch und sie haben
es gehört es wird ziemlich heiß in den
kommenden tagen bei 27 bis 36 grad gibt
es morgen im süden viel sonne im norden
einige wolken an den küsten weht ein
frischer wind bei 23 bis 27 grad am
dienstag werden bis zu 40 grad erreichte
am mittwoch gibt es im westen gewitter
christian sievers begrüßt sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und wir
sagen danke und tschüss und freuen uns
wenn sie morgen wieder dabei sind hier
gehts weiter mit dem sommerinterview und
mit theo koll